okay so if you have your lives triangle
here ABC what we want to add in Xi'an
excuse me is it interval between a B and
AC that's parallel to this bottom side
okay so something like this yes like so
okay now once you've drawn this year we
should give the name let's call it se PQ
okay in this bottom part of the shape
you can see what shape is that at the
bottom the bottom half of this it's a
trapezium very good seeing you see
parallel lines this trapezium is a pair
of diagonals okay so would you draw
those two diagonals in now this looks
like one of those questions rather like
how many triangles are there in this
diagram people with an IQ over 150 can
find 18 tribe will see like a series
okay now are there are no object now
there's a particular pair of trials then
I'm interesting here and I will help you
see them by coloring them a little bit
so if you have some college you might
like to do the same these two diagonals
have created a big triangle here on the
right hand side that looks like this APC
okay you see that one so it has one of
the diagonals as its base and then using
the armored diagonal now i'm going to go
Christmas ooh let's this do that on the
other diagonal I have another triangle
okay so i'm going to call it a VQ like
this okay so you can see that overlap
right now the question simply is our APC
a QB what's the relationship between the
two areas what's the relationship
between red and green
now I'm not going to tell you just yet
what the property is that I'm going to
explain to you I just wonder if we can
actually tease out the property through
understanding the relationship what does
it look like I just on your intuition
just like air I'm just guessing do they
look they're both the same they look
pretty cuz cuz my diner is so awesome
they look quite similar to each other
don't they okay a question always is in
mathematics we often make guesses right
like in real mathematics you don't have
a book with questions and it adds to the
back and like well actually just try and
work through and then I check at the
back and find out okay in real
mathematics there's no answer at the
back you just like I wonder what it is
and then you'll play lies you can see if
you can confirm for yourself whether
your guess where your intuition is right
ok now if we think it's the same what
can we use that we've looked at this
morning then can prove to us or disprove
because we might be wrong where they are
the same or not any takers any takers
okay so i could think oh maybe there's a
parallel line i'm missing i could put
one up here I absolutely could I'm going
to suggest maybe I have and I've
parallel lines already on the diagram do
you do us differently yeah okay I'm
looking for some altitudes which
altitudes were looking for okay so i'll
pick you here right from where to where
would you let me draw you said some
altitudes where would you like me to
draw altitudes okay so by the way can I
just say right yeah when you learn a new
topic right you're like ah we have to
learn all this new words and notation
and that kind of stuff and we talked
about this why do this and the reason
why is because language is powerful if
you can talk about something articulate
what's going on that's it incredible
skill to take on board right so maybe
the leg reach out there searching for is
like are you talking about these legs
yeah is that were you talking about you
took yeah yeah yes okay while just going
to run with that okay if I put in these
two nights here okay these two intervals
do you see this sandwich between these
two power of the light speaker be seen
right so these two here right but
because they're perpendicular and there
between pair of the lines they're also
equal to each other do you agree with
that but look but look these two
trainers at the bottom that kind of
overlap in this middle spot right they
both share PQ as a base I know it's
weird to think of it as a base you just
have to kind of to do this right but you
can see it it's exactly the same diagram
gonna get before just upside down okay
so therefore i can say how can i use my
notation here um triangle PQ babe PQ be
must be equal to triangle
help me out yeah pqc because same base
and there between parallel lines so
therefore they share the same type in
the humor hi okay now how do I get
through that to my red and green areas
what's the difference say for example
between tqb which has part of the green
area and the whole green area what part
is it missing yeah this top trade a PQ
right so for example I could add a PQ so
this edit would make this is the green
area do you agree with that right but of
course this is an equation you can't
just go adding things to one side
pictures you like it right if you add
something once a you got to add to the
other year so let's add a PQ that same
but what am I done what's this this this
is a PQ + PQ see this is the red area is
it not right so what I just show is
here's the green one over here this is a
be cute do you agree and this kind of
the right is a p.c so like your
intuition said the green area and the
red area are in fact the same okay
that's kind of nice so what okay right
here's where we're going to finish by
the way I guess the name for this
property and you don't need to
necessarily give it a name but it's
simply that compound Arians compound
areas like this guy right r equal to the
sum of their components that's all right
if you can work out what the components
are you can work out what the whole
thing is and by sort of cutting the
centerpieces the red and green things
you like how do you go about this well
if you if you slice it up you can work
out what the bits and relate them to go
okay so compound areas equal to some of
their components okay